[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend ihnen allen wenn man das letzte
Treffen als Maßstab nimmt dann kann es
nur aufwärts gehen die Spitzenrunde der
Entscheider von Bund und Ländern Anfang
Oktober brachte null-ergebnis aber ganz
viel miese Stimmung morgen dann die
Fortsetzung es geht um alles kann man
sagen um milliardenschwere Entlastungen
um Gas und Strom um Kosten für die
flüchtlingsunterbringung um den
Nahverkehr aber vor allem geht es um
diese eine Frage wer zahlt Klaus
Brodbeck hat mehr dazu
politik ist immer auch Inszenierung
kanzlergespräch heute Abend in Gifhorn
Niedersachsen Auftritt Olaf Scholz die
Botschaft ob Sonnenenergie Bäckereien
Bürokratie Klima oder die Nachfolge des
9-euro-tickets alles im Griff
deshalb haben wir gesagt wollen wir so
was fortführen und haben jetzt uns mit
den Ländern fast schon morgen ist der
Tag an dem es dann endgültig gelingen
soll fast schon verständigt dass wir ein
bundesweites digital buchbares Abo
Ticket einführen Deutschland Ticket
wollen wir das gerne nennen das mit 49
Euro startet wie kompliziert die Lage
tatsächlich ist wie dünn das Eis auf dem
sich bunt und Länder in den letzten
Zügen ihrer Vorbereitungsgespräche
bewegen zeigt sich auch an einer
plötzlich auffälligen Einigkeit derer
die einander sonst hier nicht schonen
letzten
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
Bundesregierung gab es ja keine
Ergebnisse und das ist glaube ich von
allen als ein
großer Fehler empfunden worden weil die
Bevölkerung in diesen Zeiten
Entscheidungen braucht ein zupackendes
handeln wir sind als Länder dazu bereit
die Gespräche sind sehr intensiv und sie
sind auch vertrauensvoll es wird morgen
aus meiner Sicht konkrete Lösungen geben
und ich glaube dass morgen mit der
Konkretion auch ein Signal wie bei der
Beschaffung von Gas und wie bei den
Aufbau von Infrastruktur der der
staatlichen politischen handlungsstärke
ausgesendet wird und hoffentlich dann
auch ein gemeinsames Signal da bin ich
ganz bei Michael Kretschmer so könnte
etwa die gaspreisbremse aussehen als
Soforthilfe übernimmt der Staat den
Abschlag für dezember ab März vielleicht
auch schon Februar soll es 80% des
bisherigen Verbrauchs für 12 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde geben für Haushalte und
bis mittel deutsche Unternehmen die
Industrie soll schon ab Januar nur 7
Cent bezahlen für 70 Prozent ihres
bisherigen Verbrauches für Krankenhäuser
soziale Einrichtungen aber auch für
gefährdete Unternehmen könnte es
Härtefallregelungen geben auch beim
Strom doch Städte und Kommunen drückt es
an vielen Stellen wir brauchen schnelle
Kleid aber wir brauchen auch höhere
finanzielle Zusagen insbesondere vom
Bund allein in Kiel wollen wir für 4
Millionen Euro neue Unterkünfte bauen
dafür weiß ich heute nicht wie ich das
Geld bekommen soll das gilt für viele
andere Kommunen auch ÖPNV Wohngeld wir
brauchen schnelle Regelungen und wir
brauchen jetzt gemeinsame
Kraftanstrengungen und da muss vor allem
der Bund noch nachlegen noch also sind
Fragen offen klar nur für alle
Beteiligten schöne Bilder für morgen ist
das nicht genug
die aktuelle Lage bringt auch ein
Traditionsunternehmen ins Wanken dessen
Geschäftsmodell und Eigentümer
allerdings schon länger für Fragezeichen
sorgen Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof an
dessen Präsenz man früher mal die
1a-Lage einer bundesdeutschen
Fußgängerzone erkennen konnte ist pleite
schon wieder jede dritte Filiale steht
vor dem Aus das sind schlechte
Nachrichten für die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter das sind schlechte
Nachrichten für bundesdeutsche
Fußgängerzonen wie viele Innenstädte bei
uns allgemein sind sie schon länger ein
trauriger Problemfall statt
Einkaufserlebnis zu vermieten Schilder
und Shops für Handyhüllen wir reden
gleich über neue Ideen wie das zu ändern
wäre kleiner Spoiler klassische
warenhaus-niederlassungen mit 70er Jahre
Flair gehören eher nicht dazu Sven Regen
wie mag es den Menschen hinter diesen
Türen gehen der Personaleingang von
Karstadt Mönckebergstraße angestaubtes
Ambiente eines Hauses des einst der
Stolz der Hamburger Innenstadt war
Spielball von Investoren
Verhandlungsmasse bei der vorherigen
Sanierung jetzt droht wieder die
Schließung nicht nur Branchenkenner
hatten das befürchtet das Unternehmen
war in der Neuausrichtung wir haben 2020
aus der letzten Sanierung
Restrukturierung und zum damaligen
Zeitpunkt haben wir bereits gesagt dass
die Schnitte die zu diesem Zeitpunkt
stattfanden also in 2020 nur Makulatur
waren da wir eigentlich sagten es ist
Platz für vielleicht 40 50 Filialen
eines Warenhauses in Deutschland und
nicht für eben 131 wie wir sie aktuell
noch haben gerade mal zwei Jahre ist die
vorherige sanierungsrunde her schon da
erwischte es 40 Standorte schon da
mussten 5000 Mitarbeiter gehen in vielen
deutschen Innenstädten klafft seitdem
eine Lücke mit den geschlossenen waren
dann gegen das letzte bisschen
Attraktivität das blüht jetzt weiteren
Städten
man muss überlegen welche neuen Konzepte
gibt es wie kann man den Online-Handel
verbinden mit dem stationären Handel wie
kann man Lebensqualität auch in diesen
Häusern schaffen vielleicht kann man das
ein oder andere auch nutzen um
Wohnbebauung zu schaffen sie wissen wir
haben zu wenig Wohnungen ich hoffe dass
es eine Lösung gibt ich hoffe dass es
auch in Zukunft noch Kaufhäuser gibt
aber es muss am Ende auch tragfähig sein
auch wirtschaftlich tragfähig eines ist
klar diese Zeiten sind wohl endgültig
vorbei das Konzept Kaufhaus in der
klassischen Form ist nicht mit der Zeit
gegangen zu lange hatten Betreiber und
Investoren auf den gewohnheitseffekt
gesetzt Corona hat den Online-Handel
endgültig salonfähig gemacht einziges
Gegenmittel ist Service der aber kostet
Personal dann will ich doch in so einen
Warenhaus gehen weil ich Beratung habe
wenn ich jetzt höre dass ein großer
Personalabbau droht dann ist ja genau
das warum ich vielleicht noch in so
einen Warenhaus gehe die Beratung ja gar
nicht mehr vorhanden
zwei Kaufhäuser an einer Straße waren in
Hamburg bereits zu viel Galeria Kaufhof
in der Mönckebergstraße muss schließen
aber schafft Raum für Kreativität eine
pop-art-galerie im Keller zeigt
ausgerechnet Werke des
streetart-künstlers Banksy dessen Name
ist bis heute ein Geheimnis ein eben
solches wie die Zahl der Galeria
Karstadt Kaufhof Häuser die noch
schließen werden die Institution
Warenhaus ist uncool geworden
Markus Diekmann ist selbst Manager er
berät Unternehmen in
transformationsfragen und er hat die
Initiative Händler helfen Händlern mit
gegründet hätte man guten Abend moin
moin wenn Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof
aufgibt ist das dann aus ihrer Sicht das
endgültige Ende der deutschen
Innenstädte nein nein ich bin mir sicher
dieses Recht hat nur die Kirche von sich
zu behaupten alle anderen dürfen auch
nach einer glorreichen Zeit gehen und
Platz machen für neue moderne und
innovative nach vorne gerichtete
Konzepte also ich verstehe sie richtig
Staatsgeld um Warenhäuser zu retten das
wäre aus ihrer Sicht keine
Zukunftsinvestition nein
ich sage mal so man hat ja hier viel
versucht aber ein Konzept was von See
von sich selber aus sich nicht schnell
genug weiterentwickelt nicht sich
verändert rassisch genug ich sage dazu
immer Veränderung ist keine Kritik an
der glorreichen Vergangenheit sondern
ein Notwendigkeit für die Zukunft und ja
dieses Warenhauskette hat so viele
Chancen sich drastisch zu verändern und
sie sind einfach nur immer mit kleinen
Modifikationen nach vorne gegangen und
damit nehmen sie auch anderen Händlern
Umsatz weg obwohl sie selber kein Geld
verdienen kann ausreichendes Geld
verdienen und sind damit dann auch
Ballast für alle anderen Händler und
töten eigentlich dann erst recht die
ganze Innenstadt dann gucken wir doch
jetzt mal ein bisschen in die Zukunft
der Einzelhandel hat ja tatsächlich
aktuell wirklich schwer massive
Konkurrenz durch Onlineshopping dann
Corona mehr als die Hälfte sieht sich
aktuell laut Umfrage durch steigende
Energiekosten in der Existenz bedroht
dazu kommt ganz aktuell die historische
Kauf Zurückhaltung bei vielen Menschen
wie sollen die Innenstädte in
Deutschland dagegen ankommen erste
Wahnsinn und ich habe meine Kinder heute
gefragt die noch sehr klein sind und ich
möchte da ein Prinzip sein also die
nächsten zwei Jahre werden wirklich
schlimm für alle und ich habe gerade
noch mit einem Chef einer der größten
reisebürokketten telefoniert und er
sagte die Frage im nächsten Jahr ist
entscheiden sich die Bürger für Urlaub
oder für den Handel so schwarz-weiß kann
man das vielleicht nicht immer sehen
aber das da sieht man mal wie wenig
haushaltsnetto noch zur Verfügung steht
Zahlen rund ungefähr 30 Prozent weniger
für den Konsum bei gleichzeitig immer
teuer werdenden Produkten das kann
natürlich nur ein Supergau Enden
zumindest für zwei Jahre das heißt man
muss sich jetzt noch schneller rüsten
als Innenstadt und das kann man nur
gemeinsam schaffen handeln mit Städten
und Kommunen zusammen und sich auch
drastischer verändern denn nur regional
Handel zu betreiben reicht nicht mehr
aus denn es ist ja sowieso der Handel
sei er seit Jahren in der Stagnation
nicht im gesamten gewachsen gleichzeitig
immer mehr Richtung online abgewandert
das heißt regionalität ist kein
Alleinstellungsmerkmal mehr sondern es
muss mehr passieren und ein Beispiel was
ich dann mal gerne nenne guckt euch mal
Ikea an ich finde das krass dass Freunde
von mir zum Ikea nach Kaarst fahren weil
es da so einen krassen Spielplatz gibt
ohne bei Ikea einzukaufen das heißt wir
müssen ganze innenstadtkonzepte es muss
mehr wohnen in der Innenstadt möglich
gemacht werden gerade in kleinen und
Mittelstädten gar nicht in den großen
touristisch womöglich noch starken
Städten wir müssen
spielplatzmöglichkeiten Gastronomie und
Wohnen und Leben in die Innenstadt ganz
ganz besonders verankern und das mitten
in die Stadt damit es wieder zum
Erlebnis wird und wir müssen uns allen
Städte und auch als Wirtschaftsförderung
drei Mal so viel anstrengen noch mehr
draußen sein noch mehr innovative und
tolle Konzepte finden und vor allen
Dingen davon überzeugen zu uns in die
Stadt zu kommen mussten jetzt jede Stadt
dasselbe machen weil aktuell haben wir
das Problem dass ja viele Fußgängerzonen
einfach komplett gleich aussehen und man
gar nicht mehr weiß in welcher Stadt man
überhaupt ist können wir vielleicht noch
kurz darüber reden wie so ein
Alleinstellungsmerkmal auch
unterschiedlicher Orte dann aussehen
könnte
absolut will ich bin ein großer Fan von
Winterswijk einer kleinen Provinz in
Holland die auch nicht als Stadt riesig
ist oder kann man sich angucken wie die
es geschafft haben tolle Gastronomie
hinzubekommen individuelle Gastronomie
aber auch super schöne kleine Läden die
auch alle wieder individuell sind oder
auch Groningen oder sonstiges das heißt
wir müssen uns als Stadt diese Aufgabe
machen diese Konzepte zu finden weil
ansonsten sind wir nur gleich gleich
reicht nicht aus wenn ich auch alles
online kaufen kann oder dann gehe ich
nämlich ist meine Entscheidung immer zu
der großen Stadt zu fahren
Wochenendeinkauf zu machen als
erlebnisshopping und das werde ich dann
nicht in den kleinen mittleren Zentren
machen das heißt wenn ich als kleinere
mittels mittleres Zentrum in Zukunft
überleben will muss ich richtig Gas
geben ein tolles Erlebnis zu schaffen
immer bestehend aus kostenlosem
Parkplätzen Gastronomie
Spielplätzen und tollen individuellen
Lokalitäten sagt Markus Diekmann von der
Initiative Händler helfen Händlern Herr
Dickmann vielen Dank für das Gespräch
und das Gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet und jetzt du
Hannah ja trotz der schwierigen
Menschenrechtslage im WM Gastgeberland
Katha will bundesinnenministerin väser
das Auftaktspiel der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft besuchen und so den
Reformprozess des golfstarts weiter
begleiten das erklärte die für den Sport
zuständige Ministerin in Doha zudem soll
es laut Faser eine Sicherheitsgarantie
der Regierung hat das für alle
WM-Besucher geben damit auch Angehörige
der
lgbtq-community gefahrlos in das Emirat
reisen können dort steht Homosexualität
unter Strafe
mit Blick auf die peking-reise von
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat
bundesaußenministerin beerbock
Veränderungen in der China-Politik
Deutschlands angemahnt Scholz müsse
deutlich machen dass faire
Wettbewerbsbedingungen Menschenrechte
und die Anerkennung des internationalen
Rechts für Deutschland Grundlage für
Kooperationen sein wer Bock äußerte sich
während Ihres Besuchs im usbekischen
Taschkent und erklärte diese Botschaft
auch dort klar formuliert zu haben bei
ihrer Reise durch Zentralasien geht es
um eine engere wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit
nachdem wegen russischer Angriffe in
großen Teilen Kiews gestern die
Wasserversorgung ausgefallen war konnte
diese vollkommen wieder hergestellt
werden auch der Strom funktioniere
wieder erklärt Kiews Bürgermeister
Klitschko gleichzeitig haben Inspektoren
der Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde
begonnen zwei Standorte in der Ukraine
zu untersuchen dort soll die ukrainische
Regierung laut Russland am Bau einer
sogenannten schmutzigen Bombe arbeiten
die Ukraine weist diese Vorwürfe zurück
in Dänemark waren heute mehr als vier
Millionen Wahlberechtigte zu
Parlamentswahlen aufgerufen und nach
ersten Hochrechnungen werden die
Sozialdemokraten von Regierungschef in
Frederiksen zwar stärkste Kraft haben
aber mit ihrem linken Parteienbündnis
keine Mehrheit im Parlament ebenso wie
das rechtsgerichtete Lager Königsmacher
könnte
Ex-Ministerpräsident Rasmussen werden
mit seiner neuen Partei der politischen
Mitte
in Brasilien hat sich der noch
amtierende Präsident bolsonaro erstmals
seit der Präsidentschaftswahl zu seiner
Niederlage geäußert dabei vermiet er
seine Niederlage explizit einzugestehen
sagte aber er wolle die Verfassung
respektieren bolsonaros Bürochef
kündigte den Beginn der Amtsübergabe an
den Wahlgewinner Lula da Silva an heute
errichteten bolsonaros Anhänger aus
Protest gegen das Wahlergebnis in fast
allen Landesteilen Straßensperren
die Israelis dürft mittlerweile
Weltmeister sein im wählen zum fünften
Mal innerhalb von drei Jahren sollen sie
heute ein neues Parlament bestimmen und
im Mittelpunkt steht einer der alles
andere als neu ist es geht nicht so sehr
umgrassierende Lebenshaltungskosten den
brisanten Konflikt mit den
Palästinensern die Bedrohung durch Iran
es geht vor allem um Bibi kommt der Mann
zurück den sie in Israel nur mit seinem
Spitznamen nennen Benjamin Netanjahu Ex
Ministerpräsident 15 Jahre an der Macht
aktuell vor Gericht wird es noch mal
wissen und er hat Chancen auch weil
seine politischen Gegner und die bisher
regierende acht parteienkoalition sich
heillos zerstritten haben aus Israel
Karl Hinterleitner
es war von vornherein klar es wird
wieder eng nach der neuesten
Hochrechnung liegt Benjamin ytan jaoo
zwar deutlich vorn mit 30 sitzen sechs
mehr als Premier ja ihr Lapid
interessanter aber das Ergebnis der
kleineren Parteien der möglichen
Koalitionspartner und da ist es knapp
der konservativ Rechte Block liegt
jetztiger stand mit 61 sitzen gerade
einen über dem meerheit in der Knesset
ein Resultat das die Spaltung Israels
widerspiegelt
heute Mittag in Tel Aviv auf den letzten
Metern der Wahl mobilisieren die
Parteien noch einmal ihre Anhänger deren
Ansichten gehen weit auseinander
ich habe rechts gewählt bibi ist ein
Anführer macht das Land stark wir
brauchen in diesem Land eine rechte
Mehrheit mit Netanjahu
ich will den Sozialismus er steht für
Gerechtigkeit und ich habe sozialistisch
gewählt
es ist ein Graben der sich durch die
gesamte israelische Gesellschaft zieht
im ganzen Land habe die Wähler heute die
Ränder gestärkt zu Lasten von
Premierminister yaya Pete dem Vertreter
des liberalen Israel
Gewinner des Abends wie es aussieht ist
Benjamin dechantiano der Ex premier mit
berechtigten Hoffnung die Regierung
wieder zu übernehmen doch allein wird
das nicht gelingen er braucht
Koalitionspartner und einer davon wäre
ausgerechnet dieser Mann Dieter von den
Rechtsextremen er löst politische
Probleme schon mal mit der Pistole hier
geht es meinen Streit um Grundbesitz so
ein Mann womöglich als Minister für
innere Sicherheit eine dauerhaft stabile
Regierung wäre mit solchen Partnern kaum
möglich meinen politische
Beobachters von Time Wunder passieren
schon mal aber wir haben ja immer wieder
gesehen wie schwierig es ist selbst wenn
die tanja ist schaffen sollte eine
Regierung zustande zu bringen er muss
dann mit den extremen Rechten klarkommen
und bei einer solchen Regierung käme
auch noch Druck von außen dazu aus
anderen Ländern das wäre nicht einfach
ist also alles offen doch für manche
Israelis spielt auch das fast keine
Rolle mehr
vier oder fünf Mal ich weiß gar nicht
wie oft ich schon gewählt habe diesmal
nicht das hat keinen Zweck es ändert
sich doch sowieso nichts das Strandleben
in Tel Aviv macht keine Pause Wahlen
sind hier keinen Grund nicht den Tag am
Meer zu genießen wenigstens darin sind
sich die Israelis einig
ja ein Tag am Meer sollte man immer
genießen fünfte Wahl innerhalb von drei
Jahren interessant ist die Israelis
wählen immer noch gern offenbar es gab
eine vergleichsweise hohe
Wahlbeteiligung heute wir gehen jetzt
live nach Tel Aviv zu Michael Beverungen
guten Abend Michael wir haben gesehen
erste Hochrechnungen ganz knapper
Vorsprung fürs Netanjahu Lager wie sieht
es denn aus nach den neuesten Trends
kommt netanjahoo zurück
also es gibt noch ein kleines
Fragezeichen weil eine arabischer Partei
knapp an der
3,25% Grenze kratzt die hier die
Eintrittskarte ins Parlament ist das
würde die jetzige Hochrechnung mit einem
Mehrheit von 61 oder sogar 62 Stimmen
für den netanjablock noch mal verändern
würde in einem pappmünden wenn es jetzt
aber so bleibt dann sehen wir einen
dramatischen Rechtsruck in Israel
benjamin ist netanjau regiert dann mit
den beiden Ultras ultraorthodoxe und
ultra-nationalistische Zionisten vor
allem letztere bekennen sich ganz offen
zu Rechtsextremen Positionen zu
rassistischen Positionen sie wollen die
Hand an den Rechtsstaat legen wollen zum
Beispiel Betrug und untreuen Amt
streichen genau deswegen steht nicht
dann ja auch vor Gericht das käme eine
Amnestie gleich und wir haben
itama Band gebührende Bericht gesehen
wie er die Waffe zieht er hat da in die
ostjerose provoziert
Autobahn soll Minister für öffentliche
Sicherheit werden das wäre dann so
ungefähr als wenn man den Brandstifter
zum Kommandeur der Feuerwehr machen
würde Michael wir sehen im Hintergrund
bei dir diese wilden israelischen
politshows eine große Tageszeitung
jediot hat heute geschrieben falls
Netanjahu triumphiert dann werden dies
die letzten Tage des Staates Israel sein
wie wir ihn seit 75 Jahren kennen was
wäre das so dermaßen einschneidende an
einer Rückkehr von Bibi
es ist nicht so sehr vielleicht die
Rückkehr von Baby aber er hat im Prinzip
Extremisten und Rassisten die hier im
Lande ganz offen von sehr vielen als
Faschisten bezeichnet werden hoffe ich
gemacht das hat es in der Geschichte des
Staates Israel noch nicht gewähren
gegeben und genau viele beobachter
bezweifeln dass Bibi selbst wenn er
diese Koalition eingeht dass er sie
steuern wird sondern und das eben
umgekehrt die Extremisten das Ruder
übernehmen und dann quasi die Kontrolle
im Land übernehmen Michael Beverungen
live aus Tel Aviv ganz herzlichen Dank
für diese Informationen heute Abend
eine Mischung aus Alarm und Hilferuf
kommt da heute vom Chef der capital
police in Washington in einem seltenen
öffentlichen Statement seine Truppe ist
zuständig für den Schutz des Parlaments
und der Parlamentarier er sagt sie
hätten tausende Fälle unter Beobachtung
die potenziell bedrohlich sein das
aktuelle politische Klima in den USA
erfordere dringend mehr Mittel für die
parlamentspolizei
das aktuelle politische Klima in den USA
ist besorgniserregend wie Annette
Brieger und MRT Wissen in einer
aufrüttelnden ZDF-Dokumentation zeigen
aus dem Versprechen von Präsident Joe
Biden Gräben zu überwinden ist nicht
viel geworden die bevorstehenden mit
Terminal actions werden für ihn zur
Schicksalswahl
die Waffe immer am Gürtel wir sind bei
den auf Keepers in Arizona einer
Bürgerwehr nach eigenen Angaben mit
knapp 40.000 bewaffneten Mitgliedern vor
allem ehemalige und aktive Soldaten und
Polizisten im Gemeindezentrum der
first-church von Gino Valley bereiten
Sie heute die Menschen auf Ernstfälle
vor Naturkatastrophen atomkriege den
Kampf um ihr Amerika wir fragen den
Anführer wie wahrscheinlich denn ernst
Fälle wie ein Bürgerkrieg sind
keine Absicht gegen unsere Regierung
zu überleben was immer politisch
geschieht
für den Ernstfall sollen die Menschen
wissen wie man schwere Blutungen stoppt
bei verletzten das jedenfalls will er
den Teilnehmern heute beibringen es soll
ein Netzwerk von Gleichgesinnten
entstehen die sich selbst und
gegenseitig jederzeit helfen können
Kurs Nummer zwei der Umgang mit
Funkgeräten schließlich könnte die
Regierung ja die Handynetze lahmlegen
was sie hier erlernen könnte auch schon
bei der Wahl nützlich sein wer will kann
mitkommen wenn die aufkepers die
Postkästen für briefwahlzettel und
Wahllokale überwachen
Jim und seine Kameraden werden ihre
Waffen mitbringen um Wähler
einzuschüchtern
wir werden nicht neben den Briefkästen
stehen sondern mit Abstand unsere Leute
sind nicht autorisiert irgendjemanden
anzugehen
diesem wahlbriefkasten kamen sie vor ein
paar Tagen aber doch so nah dass Wähler
sich von ihnen eingeschüchtert fühlten
in jener nach den maricopaccounty
verschwanden sie als besorgte Bürger den
Sheriff
am Abend sind wir ins kotzdale einem
Vorort von finis die Menschen hier
gehören eher zu den wohlhabenderen sie
freuen sich auf ihre Gouverneurs
Kandidatin sie gilt als eine Art
weiblicher Trump und bezeichnet
Zuwanderer gern als invasuch carry Lake
war Nachrichtenmoderatorin bis ihr die
Medien zu verlogen erschienen
persönliche Angriffe gehören zu ihrem
Wahlkampfstil
ich hatte eine Großmutter mit Demenz
beiden ist auch so ein Fall
kritiker halten Lake für gefährlich sie
ist für ein totales Abtreibungsverbot
verbreitet die trump-lüge von der
angeblich gestohlenen Wahl und
bestreitet dass Amerika eine Demokratie
ist was meinen Sie damit
America Amerika ist eine
konstitutionelle Republik und ich bin
begeistert dass ich so viele Patrioten
die die Verfassung verstehen um Ämter
bewerben wir werden unsere Verfassung
wieder ehren und jedermanns Rechte
wiederherstellen
bei den aufkeepers werben sie für carry
Lake und ihre Parteifreunde beim Lesen
der Patriots free press fällt uns der
Hass gegen parteiinterne trump-gegner
auf für sie erweckt die Chefredakteurin
im Leitartikel die Todesstrafe für
Hochverrat rechtfertigen Sie also
Hinrichtungen
[Musik]
wenn ich jetzt überzeugt dass man wohl
ein Exempel statuieren muss
und das im Gemeindezentrum einer Kirche
die ausführliche DoKu Trumps langer
Schatten rotland gegen blauland läuft
morgen 22 Uhr im ZDF oder bereits jetzt
in unserer Mediathek und damit nochmal
du Hannah ja und da blicken wir auf
mehrere echte Krisengewinner die Kassen
klingeln bei den Ölkonzernen und zwar
gewaltig BP und Saudi Aramco vermeldeten
heute Milliarden Gewinne deutlich über
dem Vorjahr und auch bei anderen
Energiekonzernen sieht es ähnlich aus
Valerie Haller angesichts dieser Summen
bringt jetzt auch US-Präsident beiden
eine übergewinnsteuer ins Spiel und das
kurz vor den wichtigen Kongresswahlen ja
man könnte schon sagen er droht ihnen
fast schon die Unternehmen sollten
aufhören vom Krieg zu profitieren sagte
in der Tat sind die Zahlen gigantisch
Exons Gewinn hat sich fast verdreifacht
der von Chevron ist um über 80 Prozent
gestiegen ja und laut Joe Biden hat die
Ölindustrie nun die Wahl entweder sie
investiert in Amer indem sie die Preise
für die Verbraucher an der Zapfsäule
senkt und die Produktions- und
Raffineriekapazität erhöht oder sie
zahlt eine höhere Steuer auf ihre
übermäßigen Gewinne auch BP legte heute
Zahlen vor der Ölkonzern hat im
vergangenen Quartal den zweitgrößten
Profit überhaupt eingefahren wohin gegen
Verbraucher und Wirtschaft ja sehr
deutlich unter der Energiekrise und mit
ihr unter der hohen Inflation leiden
haben nur die Konzerne und deren
Aktionäre etwas von den Riesen Profiten
BP-Aktien gegen den sonst negativen
Markttrend ganz deutlich im Plus mit 41
Prozent seit Jahresanfang das sorgt für
Unmut in der Politik rund um den Globus
die Idee ist das Profiteure der Krise
höhere Abgaben zahlen müssen in
Großbritannien gibt es so eine
übergewinnsteuer schon auch die EU hat
eine solche beschlossen in Deutschland
könnte das Geld beispielsweise dafür
verwendet werden geplante Entlastungen
im Wohnbereich zu finanzieren danke
Valerie nach Frankfurt
manchmal geht es auch ohne Streik die
Lufthansa und die werkschaft UFO haben
sich auf einen neuen Tarifvertrag für
die Flugbegleiterinnen und Flugbegleiter
des Konzerns geeinigt die rund 19.000
Beschäftigten bekommen mehr Gehalt bei
den Berufseinsteigern werden die Löhne
im kommenden Jahr um mehr als 17% erhöht
bei den Beschäftigten in der höchsten
Vergütungsstufe steigen Sie um knapp
neun Prozent der Tarifvertrag gilt für
ein Jahr zum Sport genauer zur Fußball
Champions League da traf am Abend Bayer
Leverkusen auf den FC Brügge und kam
über ein Unentschieden nicht hinaus das
Spiel endete 0:0 damit hat Bayern 04
sich aber zumindest die Teilnahme an der
Europa League gesichert
im Moment des entsetzlichen verlustsrief
sie zu Versöhnung unverständigung auf
mehr Flöte Gensch an die Verdienste der
am Wochenende Verstorbenen wurde heute
bei einem trauergebiet erinnert und zwar
in Solingen an dem Ort an dem sie 1993
bei einem rechtsextremen Brandanschlag
fünf Familienangehörige verlor sie habe
dem Hass Liebe entgegengesetzt sagte
Ministerpräsident wüst und so enormen
Einfluss auf den gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt genommen für ihr Engagement
war Gent mehrfach ausgezeichnet worden
unter anderem mit dem
Bundesverdienstkreuz
und das war unser heute schon für heute
danke Ihnen dass Sie dabei waren gern
bis morgen und unser heute journal
Update gibt es gegen Mitternacht da
spricht Wolf Spieße mit dem Präsidenten
der Deutsch-Israelischen Gesellschaft
Volker Beck zur Wahl in Israel von uns
allen hier an sie einen angenehmen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ein extremer Monat
liegt hinter uns in Österreich der
Schweiz und in Frankreich war es der
wärmste Oktober seit
Aufzeichnungsbeginn ja und für
Deutschland gilt es wird Platz eins oder
Platz zwei werden der Deutsche
Wetterdienst veröffentlicht die Daten
morgen die Klimakrise lässt grüßen der
Wind kommt mittlerweile aus westlichen
Richtungen und das relativ schnell denn
es wird windig und die Wärme die
erreicht uns ebenfalls auf der Nordseite
dieses Hochs hier ja und in der Nacht
wird es dann von Nordwesten her
ungemütlicher hier kommen Wolken auf und
Regen und teilweise aus südwestlichen
Richtungen legt der Wind dann zu nach
Süden hin wird es neblig werden und im
Osten klartes teilweise auf bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 4 Grad am Alpenrand und
12 Grad am Niederrhein morgen Vormittag
dann vor allem nach Osten Sunshine im
Süden muss der Nebel sich noch auflösen
ja und im Nordwesten da gibt es regen
teilweise Gewitter und kräftigen Wind
aus südwestlichen Richtung der teilweise
stürmisch ist ebenfalls in höheren Lagen
und im Binnenland zum Nachmittag
verabschiedet sich der Regen dann weiter
nach Osten hin und die Sonne setzt sich
größtenteils durch bei Temperaturen von
bis zu 17 Grad im Südwesten Deutschlands
und 12 Grad in Schleswig-Holstein mit
geht es am Donnerstag noch weiter
einzelne shower bis 17 Grad und ab
Freitag gibt es mehr Regen und es wird
ein wenig kühler ein schöner Abend